now that we've had more time to look
over call of duty black ops cold war
multiplayer and listen to community
reactions
it's time to round up the biggest
differences between cold war and modern
warfare and say which one we feel might
have the advantage right now
let's start by talking about movement
there's already been a bit of
controversy around movement in cold war
after the multiplayer reveal
pro players who got their hands on the
game already lobbied for greater
penalties around slide cancelling which
can be abused to aim faster and sprint
longer than other players
there are also some huge questions still
in the air around which systems will go
into war zone
for example if it sticks with modern
warfare mechanics and not cold wars then
cold war players will have to develop
two completely different sets of muscle
memory going between modes
with that in mind let's dig a little bit
deeper into movement for starters cold
war
doesn't have the tactical sprint from
modern warfare where you're able to gain
a speed boost to cover large areas of
ground while holding your gun up in the
air
instead cold war has a system where you
always get an initial boost of speed
then quickly settle into normal run
speed
this should allow you to quickly duck
behind nearby cover like modern warfare
but you won't be able to cover those
large patches of ground
speaking of running into things there
doesn't seem to be doors in cold war
i'm not sure how much you realize you're
used to doors in modern warfare
doors are everywhere in modern warfare
and you use them for cover to set up
ambushes to listen for enemy players
entering buildings we're honestly gonna
miss not having them in cold war
and probably also going to slide into a
lot of unusable doors for a long time
next up swimming it's back and honestly
it's about
time it's been very strange avoiding the
water in modern warfare
just an all-around good addition in cold
war when it comes to jumping
cold war has what they're calling a
classic jump it seems to involve a fast
takeoff with a slowdown penalty on
landing to avoid abuse
modern warfare has a different system
where if you jump rapidly
the jumps get shorter and shorter and
shorter when it comes to maps though
modern warfare has these really clever
map routes with unexpected places to
jump and mantle to
so far we've only seen more controlled
routes like zip lines and fast rubs from
cold war
when it comes to the slide cold war has
a pretty fast slide that players could
abuse in the alpha and that's
already sort of being addressed as it
stands cold war does not appear to have
executions which are honestly pretty
rare to see in modern warfare
but so satisfying when you pull them off
it's something that we'll miss in core
multiplayer but we're assuming we'll
still be in the shared war zone mode
finally let's talk about feel we're not
exactly comparing apples to apples here
since cold war is an alpha and modern
warfare has been out for over a year now
but we can't shake the feeling that cold
war just
feels a little stiffer maybe even like a
step back in how players move and
interact with their environment
we'll just have to stay tuned on this
one all right so now let's talk about
gun play and loadouts
so far gun play and loadouts are a mixed
bag of improvements and
maybe setbacks to modern warfare
starting with feelings
the recoil in cold war seems to be more
in line with black ops 4 than modern
warfare
it leans towards less recoil and more
control that probably means you can more
easily use a wider range of weapons but
at the expense of individual guns having
that unique feel they do in modern
warfare
the created class system in cold war
does seem very similar to modern warfare
with slightly fewer gun attachments by
default
it also brings back the wild card system
which means you can bring your guns in
line with the number of attachments in
modern warfare or do some slightly more
creative builds
one place create a class is a big
improvement over modern warfare is in
how weapon attachments list specific
stat changes to guns
modern warfare relies on pretty vague
descriptions of what gun attachments do
and sometimes it's just outright
confusing for example how suppressors in
modern warfare do or don't interact with
the minimap
compass and uavs right now we're giving
a slight advantage here to cold war
so now you got your guns built you're
going along you're making kills let's
talk about
score streaks cold war will have a
scorestreak system that does not reset
when you die
whether you like that or not is a
personal preference some people do like
kill streaks but score streaks make low
end rewards more accessible for more
people
and also reward you for playing
objectives you'll still need to chain
together multiple kills and objective
captures to earn score streak bonuses
that get the higher end and more deadly
call-ins
there's also going to be counter-score
streaks which is kind of a plus
currently modern warfare relies on
players to manually shoot down
deadly kill streaks like chopper gunner
it's really a mixed bag
in some random matches people are really
good but in other ones they refuse to
deal with it and your team gets
murderized
kill streaks in modern warfare really
don't incentivize support playstyles
and we really like that cold war does
something else really cool with cold war
is it gives you the actual percentage of
your contribution when you capture
objectives
now if we could only find some way to
convince random players that you only
need to hold
two of three objectives in domination
when it comes to other aspects of your
loadout cold war seems to have a near
identical field upgrade support gadget
system to modern warfare
it's based on earning momentary
power-ups over time
cold war does bring back the sam turret
which will help the average player deal
with high-end score streaks better
by shooting down air assets honestly
when it comes to building your loadouts
and classes right now
cold war seems to have a slight
advantage alright so let's talk about
modes
how are you going to feel about cold
war's modes probably comes down to what
attracted you or didn't attract you to
modern warfare in the first place
modern warfare expanded call of duty
into more milsim territory with less
friendly weapons much larger maps
and larger modes that included vehicles
like ground war
if what attracted you to modern warfare
was that it was not like call of duty
then cold war might not live up to your
expectations
if you're looking for more traditional
call of duty with improvements then cold
war is probably going to be your thing
cold war and modern warfare share a lot
of the traditional modes
so let's talk about the unique ones cold
war has two in particular vip escort and
combined arms
full disclosure i'm more comfortable
talking about combined arms the combined
arms map shown so far are 12v12
that's against modern warfare's ground
war which has 32 32.
the water-based naval map in cold war
called armada is really unique and
very interesting but we're having a hard
time seeing combined arms being as good
as the larger ground war
could be wrong here player count alone
doesn't mean more fun it's about how a
map directs the number of players it has
but for now i'm going to give the larger
map modes to modern warfare
cold war also has vip escort which is a
unique mode that seems made for the cs
go crowd
modern warfare has a number of one life
modes that can probably go head to head
with this one
and i think we just need to see more of
this in cold war to make a determination
now one interesting mode that cold ward
has been teasing is called fire team
the first sub mode of which will be
called dirty bomb in that 10 teams of
four compete to gather resources
and arm bombs that detonate and cut off
sections of the map
this sounds pretty interesting it's like
a cross between modern warfare spec
ops and warzone as someone who's
completed every spec ops mission in
modern warfare
i can honestly say that it's admirable
but kind of half baked
and cold war's take sounds much better
for now we're gonna give this one at
least in concept to cold war
there's so much more we could talk about
and cold war has more reveals coming up
what are your biggest hopes and fears
for cold war right now are you ready to
leave modern warfare
behind let us know in the comments below
thanks for watching
you